-You guys, today was
the first day of Lent.
And I thought this
was very nice.
CBS decided to give up
moderating their debates.
-Aw.
[ Laughter ]
-That's right.
Last night there was
another Democratic debate,
and it was total chaos.
Some people complained about all
the yelling,
while Bernie Sanders was like,
"This is great.
I can finally hear everyone.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, here's a good example of
what the debate was like.
Listen.
[ Indistinct talking ]
-Senator Klobuchar,
next question.
New topic. New topic.
-It was like "The View"
meets Red Bull
meets "The Real Housewives."
It was unbelievable.
There was a lot of drama
last night.
Elizabeth Warren once agai
went after Mike Bloomberg.
At one point things got so ugly,
Warren actually
picked up Bloomberg,
turned him upside down
and shook him
until a billion dollars
fell out of his pocket.
[ Laughter ]
People noticed that Bloomber
actually aired two campaign ad
during the debate.
[ Laughter ]
And people saw the ad
and thought,
"Maybe I'll vote for Bloomberg,"
and then saw him on stage, and
go, "Maybe not. I don't know."
[ Laughter ]
Not everyone had a great night
Observers are saying that Am
Klobuchar and Pete Buttigieg
failed to make an impact.
Could be the end of Klomentum.
And even worse,
we could see a Buttidrop.
[ Laughter ]
Meanwhile, after the debate --
Meanwhile, after the debate,
President Trump tried to tweet
that Elizabeth Warren
is a choker
but had some trouble
spelling the word.
He wrote she is a "chocker."
[ Laughter ]
When his staff pointed out
the typo, Trump quickly tweeted,
"lol, guys, I was just jocking."
[ Laughter ]
And this morning, Trump also
tweeted about the coronavirus,
but he tried downplaying
the whole thing.
And nothing puts me at eas
like the guy in charge of
handling the coronavirus
actually misspelling
the word coronavirus.
[ Laughter ]
What's he doing?
What's going on?
-Come on.
-Businesses are also being
affected by the coronavirus.
I saw that there's a chanc
Diet Coke production
could be interrupted.
[ Audience oohs ]
One man heard that and was like,
"Okay, now we have a problem."
[ Laughter ]
"Space force, assemble."
That's right.
The CDC is telling Americans
that the coronavirus spreading
in the U.S.
isn't a matter of "if."
It's a matter of "when."
I have to be honest, all thi
stuff is a little scary,
but as far as pandemics go
at least things
can't get much worse.
-Now to central Florida,
where a colony of
herpes-carrying monkeys
is growing in size,
increasing the risk of
confrontations with humans
[ Laughter ]
-Some business news --
I saw that Bob Iger,
the C.E.O. of Disney,
is stepping down.
He is expected to officially
announce his successor,
Bob Chapek,
by standing on a rock
and holding him up to the sun.
[ Laughter ]
[ Tribal singing ]
♪♪ Disney C.E.O. ♪♪
That's right. Disney C.E.O
Bob Iger is stepping down
and will be replaced by
a man named Bob Chapek.
Disney even released
this announcement. Take a look
-As Disney says
goodbye to Bob Iger,
we're also excited to announce
our next C.E.O., Bob Chapek,
along with the new members o
our board --
Bob Johnson, Bob Hobart,
Bob Bobson, Bobby Bobberbob,
Barbara Bobs,
Bobby Bob Thornton.
Bobwitdabob Dabob Dabob
Bobby Bobby Bobby,
shake da Bobby,
said up jump the Bobby.
And Bobby Yoda.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Hey! Bobby Yoda.
-This is going viral.
A fashion designer in Englan
created inflatable
latex trousers.
Check this out.
[ Laughter ]
It's great if you want peopl
walking up to you all day
and asking, "So what happene
to your testicles?"
[ Laughter ]
-Wow.
He was walking on
the balls of his feet.
[ Laughter ]
Hey-oh!
-This is crazy.
Today is the five-year
anniversary of the infamou
white and gold or
blue and black dress debate.
Take a look. Yeah.
Remember the good old days
when this was the only thing
dividing America?
Isn't that great?
[ Laughter ]
And finally, a poodle
in Pennsylvania somehow
made its way home to its famil
just one day after being
carried away by a hawk.
Yep, it walked in the house,
poured itself a drink and said
"You would not believe
the day I had."
We have a great show.